cada día en westminster parece un clavo
más para el ataúd político de boris
johnson después de un interrogatorio a
mediados de semana en el parlamento el
jueves munira mishra que había trabajado
con él durante 14 años renunció a su
puesto de jefa de política lo hizo por
la referencia de johnson a un caso de
abuso sexual en el parlamento el primer
ministro acusó al líder del partido
laborista que ir starmer de no haber
perseguido a jimmy saville cuando está
bien era director de la fiscalía johnson
de visita en blackpool y mantuvo sus
palabras
anti king notebooks
pasamos absolutamente claro no estoy
hablando del historial personal del
líder de la oposición cuando era
director de la fiscalía y entiendo que
no tuvo nada que ver personalmente con
esas decisiones me refería a su
responsabilidad por la organización en
su conjunto
sobre si el primer ministro debería
haber pedido disculpas el ministro de
finanzas
regis unac uno de los favoritos para
sustituir a johnson le dio un tibio
apoyo workout respecto a los comentarios
siendo honesto yo no lo habría hecho y
me alegro de que el primer ministro haya
aclarado lo que dijo en favor y gran
parte de la prensa británica tilda la
situación de crisis no con una sino con
cuatro renuncias de asesores de alto
nivel los tres restantes estaban
directamente vinculados a las fiestas de
downing street
johnson ha prometido cambiar su estilo
de gobierno tras el informe de la alta
funcionaria su grey que condena graves
fallos de liderazgo en relación con las
fiestas celebradas en downing street
la popularidad de johnson se ha
desplomado en las encuestas y su partido
ha caído muy por detrás de los
laboristas en los sondeos de opinión de
cara a las elecciones locales de mayo
varios diputados quieren a johnson fuera
pero no los suficientes como para
plantear una moción de confianza